we have a voicemail number 219 to david  p call anytime hears a voice mail that  came in oh my god Pat and then Dixon is  exactly what I've been waiting for all  right so clearly someone Pat very happy  with the vacation day filling that you  in bended III heard mostly positive  feedback which is weird because I here  mostly negative feedback when I'm here  it was a much different dynamic i would  say i think was a little bit more of a  casual show but i certainly enjoyed it  all right well if pat enjoyed it then i  think that that's something we should  all be uh paying very close attention to  okay on the bonus show today Paul Ryan  does not dab and much more david  pakman.com slash membership to sign up I  voted 17 coupon code available to you if  you would like